beats up for Tyler bzi naner the Calgary native
R wide for bzi walking in holds and shoots and
that's knocked Away by badar Morgan Riley sets it
back up for Austin Matthews the NHL goal scoring
leader 13 on the air Matthews throws out ahe
Knocked Down Bruce Puck go a knel and rning and
scores what move by William neander a power play
go it's one nothing Toronto and the streak goes
on almost a broken play Blake Coleman try
to jump the drop pass Matthews mishandles
it but in the broken play throws it to space
and will L that acceleration out of a pile
and then the strength he shrugs off Anderson
Anderson puts a stick on him doesn't impact at
all pulls it around badar should thr in comes
Gregor drops that back C is fired on that C's
back the other Way Conor Zer with him cadri
drps it out for Zer puts up towards the go W
the save three score Hunter Zer has points
in each of his first four NHL games that's
his second goal and there's The Equalizer 1
and quick transition chance but there's lots
of guys back in time time and the scam pass gets
across Gregor gets a stick on it but just enough
to slow it down and a choked up shot which wol
look at his stick here just shoves it and wol
spits it right back into the area of Conor Z
and he shovels it upstairs all Square start
of a three-game tour through Eastern Canada for
the Flames it go on to Ottawa and then Montreal
Robertson drops it off for DOI Rook again feeds
it back in front y scores KY garro restores the
lead and his hot streak continues three goals
in his last three games starts with this little
crafty pick up look at that out of the air by
Nick Robertson if he misses that Play Def to get
there but ycro Dives inside his cheest Lyle and
gets his stick available little saucer to space
from maxy and ldar look Shak he gets underneath
his glove Yar cro continues his fine play pick
as a guy who would start in first power play for
calary here's LOL with it back for Anderson Rasmus
Anderson back around Zer walks it and shoots
hit the goal post rebound squirts fre it's
under there's canthan With It loock Away by
KNE Lander Pi me away with Breer shoot scores
another Beauty for William elander and it's
3-1 [Music] [Applause] Toronto he just won't
score ugly goals it's just so smooth and Anderson
puts Hanahan in a tough spot on his backand naner
steps right away active stick which has been
so good all year long and there was no way he
was going to pass this Puck he was always going
to shoot it right hand shot puck in the middle
and ldar just gets beat blocked side I mean
yeah it's an awesome shot and we know we can
really Sling It Love a safe in your go Matthew
n drops that back it's poked away a chance now
for posil Martin ppil Works in and shoots and
W get a piece of that to knock it away a sharp
angle put that wide now Brody plays it back
in Riley waiting for it back around the knee
Lander Cent what a pass tamura scores oh my
goodness what a pass for the goal what a dish
he tied himself into a pretzel got hammered
and then put it right on a platter for John
tarz puck gets behind the net he knows
Anderson coming in to check them hard
here comes cadri as well and wager cadri
Anderson all of them at the goal line or
below but that's nice and you know John tar
just made a career out of being incredible
right there well Sheldon keep will like
the four a lot Mike he'll like the one
a lot better even drops that back for zadorov
shoots it goes off a leg and wide zorov shoots
he scores and zidor from a sharp angle
rockets that home and Calgary's got it
second he won't like the two nearly as much
you mentioned how how big he is how much he
can lean on a puck first one is into the ankle
what M poni and then you I think Morgan Riley
trying to slide through and block that shot
slashes through the ey line and there you get
a great there's a steal byy that pass was
blocked by Anan they have to keep you in
the NH or C A shoots Buck's mask off and
play instantly called another great look
for William neander drops it off for rear shoots
that goes High that back to Anderson the C over
a minute now and they score right in front AJ
career BS at home and Calgary's back within a
goal that's a goal against the fourth
line for parts of it again just kind
of see a little bit more time and space
that Calgary has to snap it around and
eventually the puck gets back to the
middle of the ice and by he gets body
positioned inside that puck close to
being out of the blue line but I think
that should be good and Jake mccave just
he's just catching his gra from last shift
M here's Matthews Matthews feeds it back Mar
throws it back in front kicked out by V held
at the line by jordano Mark jordano finds
it back in the corner for Matthews looks
back for mon he falls Jordan great job to
hold the line throws it back for Matthews
bouncing Tu back head shot but the save
rebound loses the side of the goal Matthews
working at free in the first 40 minutes
he has been consistently excellent on the
faceoff spot so far this season here's Coleman
shoots triples back in Fr wall down rebound
score bosil I banged it home last bosil got the
last touch on it and a tying goal for Calgary
three and A2 minutes into the third period to tie
it up good for check by POS knocks it loose on the
initial dump in and then follow the bouncing
Pockets a pinball wizard all over the map and
off a leaf stick off the cave off jordano skate
you name it it hit something on the way to wall
he never gets a hold of it frost just gets to
it first waiting for you tomorrow Le it's back
to back at home tarz moving with neander tarz
walks in and a point blank save by rebound andar
throws everything in that the rebound oh he can't
believe he missed 2017 10 plays it back shoots it
fired it wide here's Ben ju with it up ahead for
Taris with pzi and of a long shifter toar what a
move moves it and shoot lar save for tuy flips
it ahead he's got ly home and Hanahan Hanahan
two on one works in he it across little St
by wall and B taks it ahead quickly takes
the long way in Sharon goich winds in scores
was M long but he's got one here to give the
Flames the lead that's his move over the glove
and definitive call oh yeah see the net ball W
in the back wow aror has to score to extend the
shootout marer in on glar lost the puck for a
moment scor recovery by pitch marer that is so
greasy he lost the puck four times see what's
happening look at this over stick once and twice
he's almost going backwards with it underneath the
pope check du in on wall Dylan dub stop and the
Leafs win it a five more final in the shootout a